[Música]
hola bienvenidos a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo antón tusk y
no un reconocido bloguero de viajes
ucraniano dejó de lado las travesías por
lugares exóticos alrededor del mundo
para documentar como la guerra ha
afectado a la cotidianidad en su país
desde el día 1 de la ofensiva rusa como
si se tratara de un experimentado
reportero de guerra con cámara y
micrófono ha recorrido varios
territorios ucranianos entre ellos zonas
devastadas por combates hospitales
infantiles y campos llenos de explosivos
en france 24 hablamos con él y nos contó
sobre su trabajo empezamos
a lo largo de los últimos 11 años anton
tours quien ha registrado una variedad
de experiencias en vídeos subidos a su
canal de youtube donde cuenta con más de
5 millones de suscriptores la
especialidad de este bloguero ucraniano
y su principal contenido eran los viajes
pero eso cambió a partir del 24 de
febrero de este año cuando inició la
invasión rusa debido a que los hombres
de entre 18 y 60 años no pueden dejar el
país al ser requeridos para defenderlo
antón decidió utilizar sus habilidades y
experiencia para documentar lo que está
sucediendo en medio de la guerra nos
dijo que al principio intentó apelar a
su audiencia rusa que conforma la mitad
de sus suscriptores pero la falta de
efectividad del contenido lo llevó a
cambiar el enfoque y ahora le habla a
occidente desde un canal alternativo en
inglés llamado anton somewhere o antón
en algún lugar
first
primero durante la guerra tienes que
hacer algo tienes que mantenerte ocupado
todo el tiempo porque si en ello
literalmente puedes perder la cabeza por
eso tenía que hacer lo que solía hacer
normalmente que es grabar vídeos eso
primero y segundo pensé que iba a ser
útil de alguna manera para otro año
decidí cubrir algunas historias de mi
vida personal a quien quiero durante la
guerra y luego empecé a cubrir historias
en la región de kiev
el objetivo principal era mostrarlo a la
audiencia de occidente que todavía puede
hacer cambios porque siguen siendo
países democráticos justo
si son finalmente así que ven esas
historias y quizás puedan ayudar a
ucrania de algún modo se necesita melo a
sus autoridades electas oa través de
ayuda humanitaria
dentro de su contenido también está una
especie de informativo esporádico y
donde cuenta algunas de las noticias más
curiosas o destacadas que van desde
experiencias personales como cuando se
rompió la pierna tras caer por las
escaleras
por contar que fue vetado en rusia por
50 años tras querer hablarle a su
audiencia rusa también registró el
inicio de los enfrentamientos en el
donbass la caída de misiles en kiev como
lidian con los problemas de combustible
en la capital y cómo se consigue a
través de internet el lanzamiento de
proyectiles cargados con panfletos de
propaganda rusa en las zonas de combate
así como el concierto sorpresa de la
banda irlandesa u2 en una estación de
metro de kiev
a simple vista antón podría pasar por un
experimentado periodista entre sus
vídeos hay dos documentales en uno
destacó la labor de todos los
voluntarios ucranianos durante la guerra
y que van desde quienes trabajan en
cocinas comunitarias hasta quienes
defienden el país y en otro destacó la
importancia de los ferrocarriles en el
contexto del conflicto
hace un par de días en las líneas del
ferrocarril ucraniano como sabes rusia
está atacando duramente los
ferrocarriles porque son la principal
arteria a través de ellos es como
adquirimos bienes combustible ayuda
humanitaria y armas de nuestros aliados
a ucrania ya que nuestros puertos
marítimos están bloqueados y no hay
espacio aéreo y por eso los
ferrocarriles son nuestra ruta de vida
digámoslo así y pase cerca de dos días
con ellos tratando de mirar desde
adentro en estos lugares y hacer una
especie de documental no está ligado
directamente a la guerra pero hoy todo
en ucrania parece estar relacionado con
el conflicto de algún brindis green is
now and how great to work pero pese a
estar cubriendo la vida de los
ucranianos empañada por los combates
antón no se atreve a compararse con un
reportero de guerra a la labor de
quienes cubren el conflicto en esta
conversación nos contó cómo trata de
aplicar las mismas técnicas que usan sus
famosos vídeos de viaje en un formato
para recoger con mucho tacto y mucha
sensibilidad las historias de las
personas que pasan por su lente
[Música]
lo que yo hago lo hago por mis propios
medios empecé como una especie de
presentador de un programa de viajes y
pasé año y medio en este proyecto indie
destrucción de tweets y luego renuncie y
empecé a hacer todo por mi propia cuenta
así que me acostumbré a esta especie de
flujo de trabajo estudis canal
workshop escribir evitar grabar hablarle
a la cámara todo por mi cuenta es algo
muy común en youtube mucha gente lo hace
a mí ni se critica moncín y pero durante
la guerra no necesitas hacer una especie
de documental bonito porque no es el
punto el punto es la historia y estoy
tratando de hacerlo lo más profesional
que puedo porque me acostumbré a ello
porque con los vídeos de viaje tienes un
enfoque distinto y trouble ground y
brain y viajar alrededor de ucrania es
algo muy bonito así que hago un esfuerzo
mostrarlo tanto como puedo es match del
club antón ha dejado claro que no hará
más vídeos de viajes hasta que la guerra
haya acabado un escenario que sigue
pareciendo cada vez más lejos así
despedimos esta edición de revista
digital gracias por acompañarnos
recuerden que si quieren repetir esta u
otra misión de nuestro programa lo
pueden hacer a través de nuestra página
web www puntos france24 puntocom
[Música]